Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie whole bunch of
flash knowledge bombs dropped this weekend
so this is going to be my top 10 predictions
for the rest of the season.
There is a new round of the flash ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video winners
always announced at the end of videos so be
sure to click that bell to enable alerts so
you don't miss anything.
So we gotta talk about black flash.
We gotta talk about Grodd Solovar and while
I'm doing this let me know if you think the
audio is a little bit better than my previous
videos I just change the way you do little
bit, so top 10 predictions for the back half
of the season.
Number 10 Jesse quick and Harrison wells of
earth two will be back very soon.
The reason they're not on all the time is
just because they have so many characters
already and they wanted to feel different
fresh with new characters or albeit in a different
characters with new personalities Tom Cavanagh
who plays like a different version of his
character every single season so because they
want to feel like there's all these Jesse
quick adventures happening on earth two wall
were having all the adventures on earth one
with regular team flash, they just have to
allow that to exist by itself in the just
choose to fill in when she tell stories like
oh my God I had all these adventures or even
if she ever goes off on one of the new spinoff
TV shows.
So there's always the chance they could do
like a teen Titans or young justice live action
show so Jesse quick would be like the prime
candidate for that if she's not to be on the
main flash of every single week or she can
always go to legends of tomorrow the future
season, but number nine that also means that
earth.
19 Harrison wells will be here at least long
enough to introduce us to earth.
19 flash who seems like he's going to be a
big part of the gorilla Grodd episode, so
no idea as if he's going to stay for the entire
season, but he will be here for a while longer,
I know we came on kind of strong, but that
was him, just like laying it on thick, so
that the team would like him.
Now that they've cooled off a little bit.
He's cooled off a little bit.
So I don't think you can be quite is crazy
in the back half of the season will still
be very different from earth two Harrison
wells, but that just because he's a different
character so we can all lay bets when we get
the season for predictions on what new character
Tom Cavanagh's going to play.
So, I know everybody thinks that he has some
secret agenda beyond the book that he's writing
a really his core mission the back half of
the season is in the launching the star labs
Museum kind of like they had on earth to which
I feel like as a precursor to the flash Museum,
which will eventually see on the show, but
maybe not this season number eight.
This is a big one earth.
19 flash the accelerated man will be someone
different than Barry.
So what I think the gonna do is is if they
want to have them on screen with grant Gustin
at the same time.
It would just makes sense that you would use
a different actor.
It would be like a different person from Barry.
So they could interact with each other and
have a really cool adventure.
There are number of different people that
it could be.
If it's gonna be someone that we've seen before
like only got.
I can't believe he's the flash of another
earth but the thing is is the accelerated
man is from grant Morrison's mulch diversity
storyline, which is kind of noncanonical like
it's like this weird spinoff story that exists
by itself, but in that story you never learn
who's underneath the mask you just see them
in that red Baron looking costume with the
scarf wrapped around his face.
So he's like a really small one off character
they could just do the same thing and never
revealed who's underneath there yummy you
just guess just based on the way his Highline
looks even if he doesn't take the scarf off
in the episode will have to listen to him
speak at least a little bit.
So will probably be able to figure out who
it is, but number seven the gorilla Grodd
two-part episode will take place on gorilla
city of earth two not earth.
19 as previously believed.
So the whole reason that everyone thought
that the gorilla Grodd episode would take
place on earth.
19 was because of the presence of earth.
19 flash, so everyone's like oh okay were
going to go to our new Harrison wells from
earth.
19 earth will meet his version of the flash
even told us that they have a gorilla Grodd
and a gorilla city on earth.
19.
So everyone's like okay got it.
But then this past weekend at the TCAs the
producers dropped all these flash knowledge
bombs and said that would actually be on earth
two gorilla city, which makes sense because
it would be our version of gorilla Grodd that
we be seeing again so it's a little more meaningful,
but it also complicates things because you
how you get to earth.
19 flash was he doing there, so next big thing
were on earth two number six will finally
meet Solovar will be voiced by Keith David
who, you probably remember from a whole bunch
of stuff but because he's only going to be
using his voice.
I think more about the animated stuff that
he does my very favorite Keith David character
is reverse giraffe from Rick and Morty he
is Apsley amazing, no matter what he does
but the Rick and Morty stuff is crazy or maybe
just maybe were all real.
You know may I'm reverse drive I have a short
neck and legs.
I went to college with camera.
I saved goes to the does life in Vietnam and
Beth how many times have I been a shoulder
for you to Crile till many okay so maybe which
is whole thing, so you don't know.
Solovar is I'll talk a lot more about him
when we get to that gorilla city episode,
but he's basically the good gorilla in this
planet of the apes style fight with gorilla
Grodd gorilla Grodd is one of the biggest
flash villains, we haven't really seen him
be a villain on the series before he just
someone the gets co-opted by the reverse flash
and is a villain of circumstance he doesn't
want to kill people.
He just wants to create more intelligent guerrillas
so that he isn't so lonely but now he's found
himself in gorilla city on earth two with
other intelligent apes.
So he's probably try to seize power, Solovar
is the other side of that equation like the
Caesar in the planet of the apes equation.
If you haven't seen that movie Caesar isn't
an evil AP somebody that starts out as a good
character he winds up fighting for dominance
with another aide that wants to kill all humans
so becomes this big mess.
So is gonna be like battle for the planet
of the apes only with guerrillas so battle
for the planet of the guerrillas but if you've
never read the comics gorilla city is amazing
we'll talk all about it when we get closer
to that episode, so number five we will see
Barry the trade the team in order to save
Iris we've heard savitar's flash prophecy
one of the people is going to betray team
flash they were like centered on Cisco the
camera was looking at him when they said that
part of the prophecy, but I actually think
that in small ways Barry is going to betray
the team because he hasn't told everyone what's
going on with Iris in the future and he knows
that he can't change the past but now he's
worried about taking actions that will lead
to Iris being killed, so he's trying to avoid
that future by doing different things.
So that's a big thing in the next episode
you will see him afraid to take down plunder
because he knows that if he takes plunder
down it might lead to Iris being killed, so
this is only the beginning like you see him
drawing on this board here he's going to try
and work out how to change the future by taking
different actions, but most of us who have
watched time travel stories know that self-fulfilling
prophecies tend to work against you when you
try to avoid them like whatever you try to
do it's always going to lead to that moment
time will always find a way to replace the
terrible thing that you're trying to avoid
which is really interesting because that's
the reverse flash quote he told that to him
in season one in now.
The reverse flash is over on legends of tomorrow
trying to change time to get rid of Barry
the reverse flash actually has a plan to make
that stick involving the Spear of destiny,
I'll talk more about that in my legends of
tomorrow videos because it's all about getting
rid of Barry Allen.
But there is trying to change time to save
Iris, so number four.
Like I said you know time likes to replace
terrible things with equally terrible things
were gonna see Iris die more than once in
that moment.
So when keeping with the theme that Barry
is going to be unable to change time at least
in the short term organist see that moment
again now.
Lot of you vest like is Iris West going to
die this season Candice Patton is not going
to leave the show.
Meaning is good have to be some crazy explanation
for how Barry saves her or how she comes back
right now without more evidence the easiest
way for Barry to safer is to pull her from
the timeline and just like stick her inside
the speed force a place of pure energy that
exists in this nexus of space and time in
this really weird way.
So the only real way to save her right now
is to just pull her out of space time and
that's the speed force but that doesn't mean
that he's actually going to do that, because
if you're inside the speed force that means
that savitar can also get you because he stuck
inside the speed force, so number three escaping
death, the black flash will be back but it's
going to be a different person underneath
the mask.
So there's any confusion the black flash is
a little bit different from zoom is a little
bit different from the black racer, there's
a lot of different flashes that where black
costume.
So I can get a little confusing the black
flash originally started out is sort of this
meta-concept of villain created by Grant Morrison
and Mark Mullarkey to come for Wally West,
so that Wally could metaphorically and literally
escape death like his own death was chasing
him.
He was able to outrace it.
So is kind of a metaphorical story like it
was their way to show that Wally had of vault
is a human being as a flash is a character
his powers had gotten to the point where he
was so good that he like broken the mortal
chains and could literally outrun the concept
of death.
Meaning that he was affectively immortal.
This all happened right before Geoff John's
started writing on the flash but then later
during Geoff John's run he actually turned
him into more of a physical character during
Geoff John's run he started using the character
is more of an antagonist.
So on the TV show it's more of like a Geoff
John's black flash someone who comes proceeding
the death of the speedster.
So he only shows up when a speedster is getting
ready to die.
It could be any speedster not anyone in particular.
So when the black flash is killed or dies
a new flash takes his place so there was a
brief.
When Barry Allen during Geoff John's run became
the black flash and later eobard Thawne Prof.
zoom became the black flash during blackest
night, so couple different versions of the
flash have been the black flash.
But on the TV show it zoom, so when he comes
back it will be the black flash is not to
be zoom coming back and because the actor
who played zoom is on another TV show they
just said that.
It'll probably be somebody else underneath
the makeup when you look at in here like you
can't really tell.
This is Teddy's ears like it just looks like
a lot of CG was not really that big a deal,
but it is the same zoom but you have to imagine
that going through that transformation, changed
his personality.
So, to be more like a zombie story and we'll
talk more about this when I do season for
predictions.
But this also gives them a backdoor to do
a blackest night zombie storyline in season
for like a black flash team up of evil flashes.
The other really cool thing about that is
they said that the black flash will show up
on multiple TV shows, which makes it sound
like he's gonna come for the reverse flash
on legends of tomorrow.
So will just wait and see about that number
two though is that we will see human form
savitar will learn what he looked like before
he learned to create his speed force armor.
So there is a person who is savitar even though
he's like a full CG villain right now with
Tobin Bell from the saw franchise doing his
voice, so that sort of like monster form savitar
who calls himself a God.
But as we know he's not a God, you just need
to get people to believe that you're a God
in order to make it true.
So eventually towards the end of the season
will learn what he looks like when he doesn't
have his armor on like that right now he sort
of stuck in a state between pure energy in
the speed force can be an actual physical
person on earth so he's going to be like this
until the flash learns how to defeat him,
so that's probably going to be most of the
back half of the season, but speaking of shiny
suits number one we will see Barry in a new
flash suit.
So there's a couple different ways this could
happen grant Gustin already teased that it's
time for Barry to get a new suit.
So what happens each year on the flash is
that they upgrade the suit just a little bit
like we go from the red emblem to the white
emblem Cisco add special new abilities.
The only thing that they haven't done yet
but they've teased is the flash ring, so that's
going to be one of great but I also think
that because Barry keeps trying to see the
future we will see a future version of the
suit like he's slowly becoming the future
flash the more antagonistic one that goes
against the group because of this Iris situation
is driving him crazy.
So it's putting him at odds with the rest
of team flash, so that's where you have your
future flash storyline where Barry sends in
the message don't trust anyone.
You can't trust me which gets in the legends
of tomorrow plot changing time future flash
war.
So there's just like so much craziness that
they've teased that they have left to do so
in case you forgot it.
Don't worry.
I'll be doing bonus videos for everything
as we get closer to the season it's still
a couple weeks away, there's probably going
to be a new trailer next week if you guys
have requests for bonus videos just leave
them in the comments but congratulations to
the new flash giveaway winner resident evil
freak 500 you win a reverse flash ring please
private message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details for those
that are asking giveaway winners are always
announced at the end of videos so make sure
to stick around to the end of videos so that
you know whether or not you won a giveaway
and it's the same for all the videos that
I do so new Batman movie stuff coming tonight
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to learn about Thor Ragnarok and
the death of the Marvel universe can click
here to learn all about gorilla Grodd on the
flash thank you so much for watching I'll
see you guys in the next video!